[Music]
q4 of this year is going to be insane
shocktober when you hold up for when
you're playing football
fourth quarter fourth quarter in the
fourth quarter fourth quarter
yeah they had us the first half i'm not
gonna lie fourth quarter baby they had
us the whole game but it's all about the
fourth quarter fourth quarter fourth
quarterback hold it up this is your time
their time
is done
the chairman of the federal reserve
explicitly saying no intention to ban
bitcoin obviously bitcoin is going wild
on the internet el salvador has started
to mine bitcoin using energy from
volcano the apex predator of the
financial markets is ready to roll you
play to win the game
hello you play to win the game going to
the fourth quarter of the football game
but they are who we thought they were
and we let them off the hook we can
fight our way back
into the light
we can climb out of hell we will not go
quietly into the night and remember what
got you here focus on the fundamentals
we've gone over time and time again we
can't be consumed by our petty
differences anymore
[Music]
we will be united in our common
interests we have won every single game
we have played till now
so this team
is perfect
we'll give us a little four fingers in
the air for the fourth quarter
how we gonna finish it how are we gonna
close it out fourth quarter
[Music]
good morning good morning good morning
welcome back to the best business show
the most dangerous business show bitcoin
all-time high
we told you so that's the theme of
today's show no just kidding bitcoin
all-time high congratulations to
everyone lots and lots of people all
holding on to bitcoin this is what
happens when you have an asset that is a
finite supply demand increases price has
to go up to accommodate everyone this
business show is the show that my
brothers and i wish that we had when we
were learning about business investing
in finance today is going to be a wild
one i've got joe and john both here with
me and how do you know their names are
joe and john real simple their names are
on the back of their chairs
today we have liz young from sofi coming
on the show she's going to explain from
the institutional perspective everything
about bitcoin how it fits into a
portfolio then we have anthony
scaramucci from sky bridge coming on
filled with laser eyes ready to rock and
roll he promised me it would be a wild
segment so we'll see what exactly that
ends up meaning do not forget bitcoin
all-time high i got you 21 off in the
store that's right this bitcoin
laser-eyed bull shirt 21
off this jerome powell thank you thank
you you want to pump bitcoin to the moon
keep printing buddy all time highs 21
off
few 21 off
guess what we also we are satoshi 21 off
john's got the payment bitcoin shirt on
21 off he's got the bitcoin 100k hat on
twenty one percent this is one percent
off today
joe's got on the sweatshirt we are ready
to rock and roll today bitcoin all-time
high let's go straight to the charts if
we're gonna start off the show you know
what that means means we're gonna check
the charts and when we go ahead and we
look bitcoin up big today couple of
percent which means that we're starting
to get thousands of dollars in single
24-hour movements compared to other
assets bitcoin is dominating up 3 000 up
even more now almost at 67 000 that's
how fast this is moving we screenshotted
this about an hour ago to put it in here
if we then go and we start to look at
the actual underlying comparison of the
roi of bitcoin what you find is that
bitcoin is up 433
over the last 12 months gold is down 7
they have printed trillions and
trillions of dollars they've manipulated
interest rates lower and the entire
financial world has dropped gold and
chosen bitcoin to be the inflation hedge
asset and that's where you see that 433
increase over the last 12 months if you
go and you look five years ago now if
you had bought bitcoin five years ago
and held it to today you're up over 10
000
absolutely bonkers numbers that's a 10x
higher
percentage
return than the s p 500 if we then go
and we look at the bitcoin price closing
history well if we're at an all-time
high that means anyone who has ever
bought bitcoin and held it till today is
up in terms of purchasing power they
have successfully protected and
appreciated their purchasing power never
a single day above the price that we
currently sit at right now that is the
beauty of an all-time high of an asset
and so if we go ahead and we look at the
actual market cap of bitcoin and some of
the other fundamental metrics we can see
bitcoin now up over 1.25 trillion
dollars with the recent price movement
bitcoin settlement over the last 24
hours over 20 billion dollars settled on
chain and the miners got paid 60 million
dollars in the last 24 hours to secure
the bitcoin blockchain 60 million
dollars to people all around the world
to plug in machines and secure the
strongest most decentralized computing
network in the world that is the beauty
of an economic incentive so absolutely
crazy watching this all play out now if
the price is going to hit an all-time
high lots and lots of other metrics also
hitting all-time highs we have the
market cap obviously hitting an all-time
high of 1.25 trillion we also have the
bitcoin lightning network capacity
hitting an all-time high we look at this
we've got
3113 bitcoin now you can see it right
there overlaid on top of price
3113 bitcoin and lightning network
capacity all-time high and then of
course if the price continues to move
upwards we have 22 363 dollar bitcoin
realized price the realized price
continues to hit all-time highs just as
much as the actual spot price does as
well and so whether
you hold bitcoin or not it is undeniable
now that buying it and holding it till
today has been a good decision what we
are watching is an asset that remember
85 of the circulating supply has not
moved in the last 90 days demand is
increasing we just had the etf launch
yesterday on top of that interactive
brokers opening up rias and there is now
billions of dollars starting to flow
into the market but once we break an
all-time high that all-time high of 64
000 about 850
there is nothing above that price point
literally there is almost no supply
above the previous all-time high and so
we enter something called price
discovery and the question is how far
and how fast do we go up do we go up to
67 000 where we're basically at right
now do we go to 70 75 80 85 90 95 100
there is going to be price discovery in
the past when we've broken previous
all-time highs there's been material
appreciation of price we continued to
talk about this all summer long all of
q3 and into the beginning of q4 you
can't say that you weren't warned if you
watch this show when we watched the
price break joe and john what was your
reaction there's a lot of yelling and
screaming and a lot of yup that was
exactly what we expected to happen at
some point well i'm pumped obviously i
mean look like we all own bitcoin we're
very clear about that uh so so from a
personal standpoint yeah it's great but
also it also means that every single
person that has ever purchased bitcoin
and held until today is now in the
profit right so there's people that in
the last run up and when i went to 60 65
000 last time maybe they learned about
it at that time period maybe that was
the uh you know the span of time where
they got a lot of their money into the
market put a considerable amount of
their savings or whatever right so it's
good to know that every single person
that bought the asset and has held onto
today with strong conviction is up in
profit and then to your point i think
like this is really just the beginning
right like we we waited for this and
it's a cool uh moment to see it break
the all-time high again and it's uh
certainly rewarding uh from that aspect
but from the thought process of look
countries are buying bitcoin uh
corporations are putting billions of
dollars of bitcoin on their balance
sheet and have said publicly they're not
going to sell uh etfs are being approved
institutions are uh buying lots of
bitcoin and coming into the asset class
and then when you talk about it from the
supply side 85 of it right has not moved
in 90 days so we're gonna see kind of
how that trends over the next month or
two uh but i would be surprised yeah if
we're not considerably higher 80 90 100
000
rather soon i would i would john what do
you think i'm pumped i'm looking forward
to 100k and a lot higher i mean this is
it's going to be another milestone i
think right so every time we've broken
the all-time high we've gone around what
8.8 x um up over the next like 12 months
or so so i'm excited to see what is
about to happen the stock to flow model
for plan b is still on track that means
we're going to have to stay above what i
think 150 000 for a very long time so i
think this is just another milestone i'm
obviously very excited but uh there's
there's more to come in my mind all
right so now on top of this we are
almost at a thousand likes here's what
we're gonna do for the giveaway today
remember the best business show free
content you come here all you have to do
is hit the like button that's the entry
do the same every
oh learn laugh earn
here's what we're gonna do every
thousand likes we cross over i'm giving
away a thousand dollars worth of bitcoin
to one person that's what we're gonna do
i will do this until we stop getting
likes every thousand likes i'll give
away a thousand dollars worth of bitcoin
so on the count of three one two three
smash the like button i'm gonna pick one
person right now to start the show off
to give a thousand dollars a bitcoin we
hit all-time highs you come here to
watch the show i give out bitcoin it's
real simple on the count of three i want
you to leave in the chat just drop your
twitter account you have to do anything
else drop your twitter account or you
can drop an instagram account too if you
don't have twitter twitter or instagram
leave your account right now in the chat
we're gonna pick one person gets a
thousand dollars in bitcoin all-time
highs my gift to you i appreciate you
guys showing up over and over and over
again every single day what that's an
all-time gift for an all-time high oh
we're gonna get
probably that's just the beginning we're
already at 1.6 yeah
bitcoin today let's go listen i
appreciate you guys showing up here
every day we're gonna do the best we can
to uh to educate you you're gonna keep
going ahead smashing the like button
john you're picking who's getting a
thousand dollars all the pressure's on
john right now to give out a thousand
dollars of bitcoin to one person who you
got john
okay don't have us be anticlimactic here
all right i got someone who you got
paris fisher pga paris fisher pga you
win thousand dollars in bitcoin
congratulations paris congratulations
let's go
need a little energy in the room today
if we're gonna keep watching 200 more
likes 200 more likes i'll give out
another thousand dollars worth of
bitcoin you guys keep smashing the like
button paul tudor jones went on cnbc
this morning they cleared out the
schedule for paul tudor jones pcj comes
to town everyone off the set one-on-one
interview with a little bit of remote
help he had a bunch to say and frankly i
think that paul tudor jones is one of
the clearest thinkers when it comes to
macroeconomics right now and what you as
an investor can be doing with your
portfolio he had four specific talking
points the first is that inflation is
worse and will be worse than most people
anticipate the second is that the
greatest threat to markets in society
right now is inflation the third was
that the most appropriate the most
inappropriate monetary policy in his
lifetime is occurring right now and the
fourth is that bitcoin is his preferred
hedge to inflation well above gold so
we've got quotes from him here the first
quote says quote i think to me the
number one issue facing main street
investors is inflation and it's pretty
clear to me that inflation is not
transitory directly going against what
the mainstream narrative it's probably
the single biggest threat to certainly
financial markets and i think to society
just in general paul tudor jones one of
the best investors in the world coming
out and saying the truth which is all
this nonsense about inflation being
transitory is nonsense it is not true
we've had persistent multi-month five
plus percent cpi inflation absolutely
bonkers but it's not just a concern in
an academic sense it hurts people there
is 45 of our society that holds zero
dollars in investable assets inflation
is eating away at their wealth it is
stealing their purchasing power it is
making every single item in their life
go up in terms of cost and rich people
who hold assets are benefiting from this
so literally you have the rich people
cheering it on because they're getting
richer and richer and richer bitcoins
going up everyone's celebrating stocks
are going up everyone's celebrating but
those who hold no investments are
getting punished the key to this don't
complain you will not change it i will
not change it nobody will change it
educate yourself and learn what are the
rich people doing so that i can protect
myself so that i can benefit just like
they can you have the opportunity go
ahead and get invested doesn't matter
what asset go get invested the second
quote we have from paul tudor jones says
inflation can be much worse than what we
fear we have the demand side of the
equation and that is 3.5 trillion
dollars greater than what it normally
would have been
just sitting in liquid deposits they can
go into stocks or crypto or real estate
or be consumed so that's a huge amount
of dry powder just sitting waiting to be
utilized at some point which is why
inflation is not going away the people
who have been telling you that inflation
is transitory are either ignorant or
stupid that is the only reason why you
believe inflation is actually transitory
when you understand that they have
printed trillions of dollars and they're
stuffing it in every crevice of the
financial system we got the high levels
of inflation that they said was never
going to come and now you have paul
tudor jones saying inflation is not
going to go away they definitely are not
going to take the prices down on an
aggregate basis and he believes that we
will continue to have a high rate of
change uh an increase in inflation
moving forward and then lastly he said
it's absolutely dead for a 60 40
portfolio for a long stock long bond
portfolio so the real question is how
you defend yourselves against it paul
tudor jones the legend of wall street
calling for the death of the 60 40
portfolio if you're sitting in a 60 40
portfolio right now 40 of your portfolio
is losing money that's how bad it is and
so obviously when you have one of the
best traders in history talking about
this people start to pay attention
now he was asked specifically about
bitcoin and cryptocurrencies and he had
to say that bitcoin and crypto is
obviously winning it has been a great
trade he still has single-digit
percentages of his portfolio allocated
to the space but that bitcoin is his
preferred inflation hedge over gold
again we talked about over the last 12
months on a nominal basis gold is down 7
on a real rate basis it is down over 12
gold is dead we can have a funeral for
it drop gold you literally held gold and
you lost instead bitcoin up 400 plus
percent paul tudor jones looked like an
absolute genius when he was on
television last year telling everyone i
have to move into inflation hedge assets
and i believe that bitcoin will be the
fastest horse how accurate and on top of
this has paul tudor jones been oh he's
definitely accurate but i i think about
it in two ways right so one is you're
right gold is dead you can look at it
from the past year two years five years
ten years whatever we have had uh really
really really bad inflation for the past
year along with the uh pandemic and all
this other stuff stimulus going on and
everything gold should have performed
well it didn't right it's an older asset
when it comes to inflation hedge and
there's obviously new assets like
bitcoin that have taken its place
secondly i think the biggest thing to
think about is we talk about this all
the time but the bottom percentage of
earners in this country get hurt the
worst with inflation right and everyone
knows this but the idea is that they
spend an inordinate amount of their
income a much higher percentage of their
income on the goods that are increasing
in price the most right rent food
electricity all this kind of stuff right
so the stuff that is increasing in price
the most they get hit with why the
people that are wealthy or rich off or
rich spend less of their money on this
stuff so i think the thing that flips a
light bulb for a lot of people who are
new to bitcoin specifically is to look
at it as a savings account right it's
just something that you're putting your
savings in so you have a certain amount
of cash that you can live on that you
need immediately to purchase uh food in
case of emergency stuff like that right
but then you move everything else into
bitcoin because it's sound money it's
digi digitally scarce uh it has a
constraint or fixed supply right and you
can predict kind of the supply and
demand equation it's historically
appreciated in price right and it's
something that protects your purchasing
power so i think when you look at it
more as a savings account versus a
speculative investment that new people
kind of come in and they assume that's
what people are doing it starts to make
a lot more sense why the average
investor and average individual would
care about it john inflation isn't going
anywhere i don't know why they're saying
it was transitory to begin with they
knew it wasn't um now they're blaming
supply bottlenecks um inflation will
continue to rise i think on an absolute
basis maybe on a percent basis over the
next year it might not be five six
percent because it's already risen so
much paul twojone hit it right on the
head um
bitcoin way better of an inflation hedge
than gold gold's up about eight percent
over the last 10 years
not looking good um people look for
eight percent returns on an annual basis
not a decade basis so
i uh i would put my money on bitcoin
appreciating more over the next 10 years
versus gold and that's exactly what i'm
doing look you're also just when you
just think about it in kind of the
easiest sense possible right you're
making a bet that the newest investors
in the world the millennials the the the
new generation right that's moving into
an investing class that's inheriting
money building their own wealth and
investing in assets how many people do
you know that are 20 25 30 years old
that are buying gold i don't know a
single one i don't ain't nobody buying
literally
cash is trash and gold issues so you're
literally just making a bet that the new
investors are going to adopt these
digital assets and if we know anything
it's literally that that they live on
the internet they want digital assets
and bitcoin is certainly a part of that
portfolio when we think about paul tudor
jones saying this he completely removed
career risk for people on wall street if
you go back and you look at the sequence
of when he actually said hey i'm gonna
start allocating to this he started with
two percent he said he's gonna be the
fastest horse one he was right two he
started kind of the domino effect of
really reducing career risk or people on
wall street we then very quickly soon
after their head stanley druckenmiller
come out and a bunch of other folks
started to say hey paul tudor jones is
in i'm in as well one that's a testament
to paul tudor jones and how well
respected he is also two though was they
needed some heavyweight they needed a
legend to absolutely come in and not
only do it because they'd already
allocated but to say it to stake their
reputation put the flag in the ground
and say not only did i did it but i have
conviction enough to talk about it and
once one of the legends kind of did that
it was game on and it literally became
hunting season on wall street and every
single large hedge fund manager that's
got half a brain went and allocated to
this we got anthony scaramucci coming on
later they're buying hundreds of
millions of dollars worth of bitcoin
right if you had a large capital pool
and you didn't buy bitcoin your
investors should be asking you what the
hell did you miss this is up 400 percent
and literally people were on television
and q3 last year saying like paul tutor
jones like stanley druckenmiller i'm
getting exposure to this because it's
going to be the fastest horse how do you
miss it's your job to get allocation if
you missed major major problems now if
you're a publicly traded company and
you're sitting there with a hundred
percent of uh your balance sheet in cash
and cash equivalents and you're not
thinking about allocating to this again
shareholders should be demanding an
answer why are you sitting with 100 of
your balance sheet in cash and cash
equivalents you know that there's five
percent inflation if it was one month or
five percent question you say hey we got
caught off guard didn't realize
inflation was going to be that bad two
months hey you know what we can't move
that quick three months hey sorry you
know we're working on four months okay
what are you doing let's go you're
letting our value of our balance sheet
be eroded away and you're not doing
anything about it even if you're holding
some sort of bond you're still losing
and so what i think we're going to start
to see here is lps in these funds are
going to start saying hey how the hell
do we not have exposure to this asset
how is it that literally there's
millions of people on the internet who
have cat photos and laser eyes and they
don't even use their real names and they
front ran you how is it that they beat
you right why should i be paying you
fees and you're not getting me exposure
to the best assets what am i doing i can
just go on one of these exchanges and
buy it myself if you're not going to do
your job then on top of that you've got
publicly traded companies where uh
equity holders are going to start saying
stuff wait a minute why are we sitting
here with in some cases tens of billions
of dollars in cash or in some cases
there's some companies have over 100
billion dollars in cash what are you
doing oh you decided you're going to buy
gold from an inflation edge standpoint
cool you accelerated the destruction of
our shareholder value
we should fire you and fire you is we
probably can't remove you from running
the business but what we can do is we
can fire you from our portfolio we can
literally sell our shares and move it
somewhere that actually is going to be
better positioned and i think that's the
conversation that's coming and it's
going to piss off the mainstream media
it's going to piss off wall street but
again this asset is inevitable at this
point and if you do not have exposure
and you are a financial advisor or
you're an asset manager your client
should fire you if you are a shareholder
in a publicly traded company and they're
not putting this on their balance sheet
and they're sitting there taking five
plus percent persistent inflation on the
chin you should literally fire them from
your portfolio because what they are
doing is they are now intentionally they
are complicit in destroying shareholder
value they are letting the melting ice
cube melt there are options
in the market they can go allocate
billions of dollars into this asset and
protect their purchasing power but they
either haven't done the work or they've
done the work and they're wrong and if
they're bad at making that decision at
actually protecting the shareholder
value on their balance sheet what other
decisions are they making that probably
are going to turn out poorly it just
shows bad decision making and so my
guess is that if we fast forward 6-12
months this is going to be the
conversation everyone's having that's
saying wait a minute we now have to have
and have not the haves are the people
who have half a brain and actually put
bitcoin in their portfolios or on their
balance sheets and the have-nots are
literally the people who are still
holding on to yesteryear and what's
going to happen is shareholders are
going to rise up and they're going to
start firing them from their portfolio
right yeah no i agree look i mean that
was a long rant so there's a lot of
things to go through there but i agree
with almost all of it really right i
think the the idea is that
there are still financial advisors uh at
least here in the united states that
we're familiar with that literally
cannot pitch bitcoin as an investment to
their clients like that is wrong right
it's an asset that's been around for
over a decade now it's performed
historically really really really well
not only from an appreciation standpoint
but as a hedge against inflation in this
country right so when you think over the
last 12 24 months we're seeing five
percent inflation the unemployment rate
is high there's a bunch of things going
on and and a ton of outside factors that
make this a great investment outside of
price appreciation right so it's it's
historically done really well so i think
the idea whether it's a company a
financial advisor etc if people are
still sleeping at the wheel when it
comes to bitcoin and other digital
assets it's a shame and i think you need
to evaluate uh not only the public
equities you're invested in but also uh
the financial advisors you associate
with the advisors it's ridiculous that
some of them they can't picture their
clients but their clients ask about
their okay now we can talk about it yeah
like what are these rules going on even
worse is that we literally have banks
who are now we're trying to sell it to
their clients but the bank heads are
saying oh i don't believe in that i
think it's gone to zero jamie diamond
jamie diamond i don't want to say the
other people but there's a bunch of
people there's gonna be interesting to
see on an allocation basis when guys
like paul two or jones or anyone really
puts in two five percent and then it
grows what do they do i bet a lot of
people they don't reallocate around and
make it back down to two percent i bet
they just hold it and it will grow into
ten fifteen percent of their
i love the fact that people on message
boards and people on the internet with
laser eyes and all this other stuff
found this investment before wall street
and to be fair people come in and
they're like oh wall street's going to
ape into it and they'll make more money
and they'll do all this stuff great but
they missed a ton of price appreciation
right by waiting 10 years in 2013 tyler
and cameron winklevoss put forward the
first etf application and i think it was
tyler yesterday tweeted and said hey
it's up a thousand x since then it was
68 bucks it's at 66 000 today it's up a
thousand x
literally wall street you're late to the
game welcome to the party baby all right
what did i see the other day with the
winklevoss twins i think someone posted
a picture it was in like 2012 or 2013 or
right after they made the bet basically
and had gone public about it and i i
believe it i forget what magazine it was
but basically they called it one of the
10 dumbest ideas of the year like that's
how much ridicule people were that
magazine is probably out of business
probably
if not they should be the media industry
has been absolutely demolished and the
bitcoin industry has exploded so welcome
to uh good ideas and bad ideas all right
we just crossed over 2 000 likes a
couple of minutes ago i'm giving out
another thousand dollars with a bitcoin
right now if you're just tuning in every
thousand likes we get on this video i'm
gonna give out a thousand dollars worth
of bitcoin one dollar one like on the
count of three smash the like button one
two three hit it and we're gonna give
out a thousand dollars right now drop
your twitter account and your
your end price prediction in the twitter
account instagram account uh handle and
your end of year price prediction right
now joe's picking one person is going to
get a thousand dollars worth of bitcoin
end of year price prediction includes
your twitter account or your instagram
account and right now we're picking one
person if you are young you should 100
this is not financial advice you should
100 have uh an allocation towards
bitcoin though just based off of all the
factors that bitcoin has and your
ability being young and be able to take
risks there's no reason that you
shouldn't have at least five percent 10
15 of your portfolio in bitcoin john the
laser on bull is ready to go he's got
the smoke coming out of his eyes let's
go
thebestbusinessshow.com make sure you go
there 21 off joe who you got i totally
uh okay i'll pick first and then come on
let's go um
tony hernandez tony hernandez you just
won a thousand dollars worth of bitcoin
come on right down tony hernandez
and you know what just happened we just
crossed over two uh three thousand likes
i guess we're getting another thousand
dollars no you don't have to do anything
just drop twitter account instagram
account right now in the chat make sure
you keep smashing the like button we're
gonna pick one more john's gonna pick
who it is we're giving out another
thousand dollars worth of bitcoin we
will keep giving out bitcoin this entire
show as long as you keep smashing the
like button drop your twitter account or
your instagram account into the chat and
john who you got
let people roll in ooh john
john wasn't cool
we're waiting for that real quick i just
want to talk about one other thing the
etf yesterday launched two big data
points out of the etf launch the bitcoin
futures etf again we think that it's an
inferior product to the spot etf that
will eventually get approved but it does
allow now there is an etf that is
trading in the united states that etf
has 570 million dollars of assets after
day one absolute bonkers performance for
an etf launch second is that it traded
over one billion dollars of trading
volume yesterday between during the
market open and also after hours trading
that makes it one of the top two etf
launches of all time we've got eric from
bloomberg here who was on the show
earlier this week absolutely crazy
numbers coming out of that futures etf
if they hadn't launched the futures etf
and had launched a spot etf my guess is
they would have done over two billion
dollars at trading volume and they'd
have over a billion dollars of assets in
the vehicle in the first day it would
have absolutely smashed every single
record but still a fantastic performance
when we look at exactly what this uh
vehicle structure was when they launched
it how short notice it was to see 570
million dollars going into it on a net
basis and a billion dollars of trading
volume pretty damn impressive uh who you
got all right um young day or well on
youtube contact paper contact paper you
just won dave718 congratulations
thousand bucks
contact paper you just want a thousand
dollars worth of bitcoin that's how
we're going to do it here we're at 3.6k
likes you know what that means if you
keep smashing the like button when we
cross over 4 000 likes i'll give out
another thousand dollars worth of
bitcoin i think we have liz here with us
from sofi we're gonna try to pull her up
here in a second and we're going to talk
about bitcoin we're going to talk about
institutional investment we're talking
about portfolio construction we're going
to talk about monetary policy liz are
you there
i'm here how are you
i'm very good how are you uh energy
today we're doing listen bitcoin hits an
all-time high you got to get a little
excited right i know i know you're right
all right let's um let's maybe just
start with kind of your perspective on
the monetary policy that we've
experienced over the last 18 months give
us a take on like what's happened and
then what you actually think of the
situation currently in terms of uh
should the fed continue should we taper
what's going on with the relationship to
inflation etc
well i think it's actually longer than
the last 18 months you have to think
back to the last financial crisis we
never really came out of that regime so
we're still in this space where easy
monetary policy is a big reason why
stocks have moved
now i think where we are is that the fed
and probably multiple central banks
around the world but the fed in
particular is in a really tricky spot
because number one they're stuck between
do we promote growth do we try to
stimulate growth or do we try to control
prices and you can't use the same tools
to do both of those things so you have
to pick which one you want more and
that's where they're going to be stuck
towards the end of this year early next
year the other piece that's going to be
really tricky for them is that we've had
such a run-up in financial stock prices
and they look at financial conditions
they don't want financial conditions to
get out of whack policy affects that a
lot so they've sort of they're stuck in
a corner to be honest and they're not
going to have an easy way to come out of
it i think that's what a lot of the
conversation is about today i mean just
look at what's happening with tapering
right they had to signal tapering for
months and months ahead of time they
still haven't said they're actually
doing it we've been signaling it for
months so we have to get people so
prepared in order for the market to
actually be able to digest any changes
in policy and that's an interesting
place to be it's a place that we haven't
seen in a long long time so we saw this
morning paul tudor jones went on cnbc
and he was talking about uh inflation uh
it's gonna be much worse than people
think it's not gonna go away it's not
transitory if you're sitting there at
the fed today do you have the ability to
actually counteract the inflation like
are they in a position you said they're
kind of put in a corner can they do
anything or do they have to just let
this run and as an investor you just
know that and so you've got to position
yourself to benefit from it rather than
suffer from it
well first of all i'm not going to
pretend to be able to be a fed official
however if i were if i were sitting at
the fed today and you look at what the
options are
tapering is really the first option that
they have i don't know that that's going
to be able to combat inflation and
without getting too granular here the
inflation that we're seeing right now is
because of a supply side issue right
it's not because of a demand side issue
so some of the things that the fed would
do to combat inflation things like
raising rates pulling liquidity out of
the system that would be to combat a
demand side issue that's causing
inflation so if you want people to pull
back on their demand because there's not
necessarily enough supply out there to
fulfill it then you would raise rates
you would kind of slow down an
overheating economy i don't think that's
where we're at i don't think that this
economy is overheating in fact you're
seeing growth expectations be reduced
through the end of the year we have a
jobs market that hasn't recovered as
quickly as we'd hoped so i don't think
we're in an overheating place i actually
think we're running the risk of getting
slow to the point where then we talk
about stagflation as an issue so the
tools that they would be able to use
yes they could control inflation if they
started to raise rates that would
control inflation it would also really
scare the stock market so that's what i
mean about them being painted into a
corner they don't necessarily have to do
anything today to control inflation
because as far as i can tell we're
absorbing it reasonably well but
something that i brought up last week in
my weekly column i don't know how much
stamina consumers have left to pay these
prices and i don't know how much stamina
businesses have left to just kind of
absorb those cost increases without
passing it all through so when we start
to think about the actual asset uh kind
of inflation that's occurring everything
is up materially obviously bitcoin is
kind of the big winner in most of these
asset classes but we've also seen stocks
go up as well is this something where as
long as they continue down the path
they're doing uh people just have to get
out of cash get into investable assets
in general whether it's commodities
equities crypto et cetera and they're
gonna do okay or do you think there will
be some level of decoupling between
these different asset classes and they
may not be all as correlated as they
appear to be today
well look the first rule of portfolio
construction is to have asset classes
that are not correlated to one another
and
it's true that in this environment where
we have high inflation we have really
low rates that cash is getting for being
just held in let's call it a money
market fund cash is really not a winning
asset in any way shape or form it's it
would just be there to sort of sit
around and not necessarily lose money
but with inflation you are technically
losing money in cash so yes i do think
that you have to get cash off the
sidelines the decision of where to put
that cash is obviously up to the
investor
here's what i would say
there are three big components of
portfolio construction i use this all
the time the first being growth the
second being income and the third being
preservation when you're trying to
decide which asset classes to allocate
that cash to you have to decide what
function they're going to play in the
portfolio now the problem in the
conundrum that a lot of investors are in
today a lot of traditional investors as
well especially the ones that have
followed the 60 40 guidelines is that
what do we use for preservation because
we used to use bonds and we used to use
cash if we're in an environment where
rates have nowhere to go but up bonds
probably don't provide enough
preservation for the offsetting equity
volatility that we have
cash in an inflationary environment
doesn't provide enough preservation
either so that's why you're starting to
see a lot more interest in things like
crypto
gold has not been the preserver that
we've wanted it to be either and it's
not the preserver that it's been in
history so you see this rise of
different asset classes new ways to do
things alternative investments much more
available to individual investors and i
think that that's a benefit you have
more options than just a regular 60 40
portfolio
what is your thoughts on the 60 40
portfolio in terms of do we think that
uh paul tutor jones is right when he
said this morning that that's kind of
dead like you just can't have that
portfolio construction in this
environment or is there some room for
that depending on what you're optimizing
for
i don't know that 60 40 should be the
starting point anymore so what we used
to talk about it as is you would start
with kind of 60 40 as the base and then
maybe you'd make changes under the
surface in that 60 40. i think a better
starting point probably puts an
alternative asset class in there so
whether you're taking that depending on
where you are on your time horizon
whether you're taking that out of the 60
which is the riskier side or out of the
40 which is supposed to be the safer
side is up to you but i i think there's
probably a third component so maybe it's
more like
50
30 you know something like that where
you break it up a certain way
i don't think it's dead but i think
we're going to go through a period of
time where the 40 does not function like
the 40 used to or the 40 does not
function really in a preserving way at
all so you have to take on other asset
classes that are going to make more
sense now
a lot of times i get the question of
okay let's say i want to start investing
in alternatives whether that's let's
call it commodities or basically
anything that's not a stock or a bond
you could put crypto in that category
too
where do i pull the assets from
you pull the assets from the place that
is not going to perform
like you intended for it to perform
or you pull the assets from the place
that you need the protection in so let's
say you're trying to protect against
inflation right
inflation is bad for bonds traditionally
so i would pull assets from that bond
allocation and put it into alternative
assets if you're trying to protect from
that particular risk if you're trying to
look for growth and this is going to be
a longer term holding in something like
crypto or in something like commodities
where you have some upside potential
although it's going to be more volatile
then you pull from that equity side and
diversify some of the equity exposure
especially in an environment where
equities have such high valuations
talk to me about bitcoin specifically in
terms of one of those new assets that it
feels like the world is kind of waking
up to starting to reprice understand
what it is how does that fit into a
portfolio today or how do you talk to
various types of market participants
that are thinking about putting in their
portfolios
yeah look everybody thinks about it a
different way i'm going to think about
it just from an investment perspective
today not from necessarily a spending or
using it as a currency perspective
from an investment perspective i'll go
back to that growth income and
preservation piece
if you believe that crypto is an asset
class that is going to grow over time
that is going to expand over time it's
already seen tremendous growth then it
functions as the growth aspect or part
of the growth bucket in your portfolio
and you have to number one have
expectations for how long you're gonna
hold that right so if you're trading in
and out of bitcoin or in and out of
crypto
it's not necessarily a growth component
that's something that you're gonna
you're gonna take on a lot of volatility
you're probably gonna increase increase
the tax component of your portfolio and
that's a completely different aspect
if you're looking at it as growth you
take it out of that equity portion and
you hold it with the intention for
holding it for the long term
you can also look at it and some people
do this look at it as preservation now
that might seem counterintuitive because
preservation typically has been things
that have very low volatility that don't
have a lot of movement in the price from
day to day obviously crypto is not that
asset class there's going to be
volatility we're still in the adoption
phase which means we're going to go
through a number of different phases of
price discovery meaning we're going to
go up we're going to go down we're going
to try to figure out where the right
price is
if you're using it as preservation
though you may want to think of it as
preservation against certain things that
aren't working like they used to and
certain things in this particular
environment that aren't working like
they used to so i'm thinking in
particular about maybe precious metals
or if you're looking at fiat currencies
we talked a lot about cash already
thinking about diversifying out that
exposure if you want to look at it as a
store of value joe and john what
questions do you guys have for liz
yeah liz mine would just be about it's
kind of similar to piggybacking off what
you were just saying we have a lot of
people on the show that uh are newer to
investing right and younger in age so
how do you think they should be thinking
about uh
bitcoin is like kind of a small hedge
right to the portfolio versus something
that traditionally would have been uh
you know something further out along the
risk curve is this something that you
recommend to younger investors or you
think that they should uh you know
either be super convicted or stay away
from
yeah i don't think you have to be all in
or all out i think that you can start to
kind of dip your toes in the water you
can think of it we call it dollar cost
averaging so you can put little bits in
at a time this is actually a point that
anthony made on my recent podcast that
once you're invested in something even
if it's a tiny little amount you pay
closer attention to it and i'll tell you
what you learn a lot faster when you
lose money so if you're invested in
something and it goes down you're
probably going to pay even closer
attention to it than you did when it was
going up and you're going to learn a lot
about how the asset class behaves
if you're a younger investor that means
you have a very long time horizon if
you're the youngest investor out there
you have the longest time horizon out
there which also means that you have the
space you have the time to put up with
some of those bumps and riskier asset
classes are then more suitable for
somebody who has a longer time horizon
so i think if you're at that phase and
you're willing to watch some of the
volatility you're willing to stomach
some of the volatility and you're going
to diversify your portfolio into other
assets including traditional assets then
yeah i think it's it's fine to start
getting into bitcoin getting into crypto
john what do you got yeah liz thank you
for doing this nice to meet you um i'm
curious so a lot of our audience is
young how do you suggest someone kind of
gets started is it kind of just putting
five dollars each month dollar cost
averaging how do you how do you think
about that
yeah so just investing in general what i
always say to people it is sort of that
dollar cost averaging but even if you
don't know what that means here's the
idea behind it
we are psychological beings and it is
very tempting when you start investing
even if you've been an investor for a
long time i still fall victim to this
and fight this on a daily basis it's
very tempting
to get wrapped up in your own emotions
about it and what i mean by that is
let's say you've chosen a stock that you
want to buy
but you haven't bought it yet now the
next decision is when do you do it right
and then you get into this sort of
circular motion of should i wait until
it goes up a little bit more should i
wait until it dips what if you wait till
it dips and it goes up another 10 and
then you missed that so you get into
this sort of mindset where you end up
actually psyching yourself out so if you
average in
on a very systematic basis
you avoid all of that completely so what
i would say is first decide
how much you want to put into the market
whatever the asset class may be so pick
the dollar amount
and then split it up into pieces let's
say split it up into ten pieces okay
take one tenth
every week every two weeks and only do
it on one day of the week so every
monday
invest one tenth into whatever that
asset class is maybe you want to spread
it out longer you do it once a month i
would say probably get it in faster but
do once a monday once every other monday
and just put the same amount in on the
same day and you completely eliminate
all that psychological gain you're gonna
play with yourself
liz when you start to think about uh
individuals who early on started to
allocate to uh assets right so
especially last year a lot of people
first time coming in they're using sofi
or various other platforms and they're
trying to get invested they're buying
stocks they might be buying bitcoin or
cryptocurrencies uh maybe even
commodities or or whatever
those have appreciated significantly how
do you think about rebalancing versus
not rebalancing should they just allow
those assets to continue to grow like
what is your kind of thought process
especially for young people as they're
just kind of starting their investing
career
yeah for young people i think
rebalancing annually is perfectly fine i
still rebalance my own portfolio only
once a year
again it gets you out of that habit of
trying to time a rebalance
now
you do want to take advantage of some of
the momentum factors which is another
reason why i would say only do it once a
year if there's a big run-up in a
certain asset class or maybe last year
everybody was invested in tech stocks
right you want to participate in that
run-up you don't necessarily want to cut
it short so a once-a-year rebalance just
to kind of get back to neutral and make
sure that you're still diversified is
probably the most prudent way to do it
if you're thinking about how do you
allocate in the first place
now there's different parts of the
market that i think younger investors
are more interested in than some of the
more experienced or older investors are
interested in
there is a bias though that we have as
investors as any human
where you end up much more interested in
the things that you know more about okay
so i'll use a simple example of let's
talk about houston texas okay there's a
lot of people in houston texas who are
involved in the oil industry they
probably have gotten paid in oil stocks
they also are probably more familiar
with that sector than most other sectors
so they have this tendency perhaps to
invest more in energy than in other
sectors but as we all know energy can be
a very volatile commodity and prices
that we have absolutely no control over
at a lot of times
you don't want to fall victim to that so
let's say if you're a newer investor and
you just happen to be more familiar with
the tech space more familiar with the
crypto space make sure that you're not
over allocating just because you're
familiar buy a couple things that you
are not that familiar with that are
going to act differently because that is
the definition of diversification and
again once you're invested in something
that you don't know a lot about you're
going to pay attention and you're going
to learn because it's your own money at
work yeah i i appreciate the fact that
you understand the kind of macro
environment the traditional asset
allocation and then you're very forward
thinking kind of open minded when it
comes to uh bitcoin and cryptocurrencies
which you know kind of hit or miss right
now uh from people coming from more of
the legacy world what's your thoughts i
know you've got this idea around like
darwinism of the crypto uh universe what
does that exactly mean
yeah so survival of the fittest right
i'll compare it to let's say micro cap
stocks you can buy micro cap stocks some
of those are going to survive some of
them are not it's a pretty risky space
the ones that survive
the the best story about a micro cap
stock is one that starts as a micro cap
grows into a small cap then grows into a
mid cap then becomes a large cap right
that's a success story now the failure
rate
on the way from micro to large though is
pretty high
right now and you'll know the answer to
this better than me but i think there's
like 8 800 crypto currencies out there
they're probably not all going to make
it right so let's think about some of
them or a lot of the newer ones as micro
cap stocks
there are some if we're going to do it
this way we would consider maybe bitcoin
a large cap at this point because it's
the most familiar it's been around for a
long time i think most investors who got
into crypto probably started by looking
at bitcoin
then the rest of them if we think about
those as micro or small caps as they go
through their life cycle some of them
are going to fall off maybe it's because
there's better technology in a different
coin maybe it's because there just
wasn't enough demand there wasn't enough
interest for it to move on and carry
forward into a more viable option so
over time because this is such a new
industry and such a new asset class
we're probably going to see i would say
a consolidation in the number of coins
but that doesn't mean that the asset
class goes away and the reason that
maybe i'm coming off as forward thinking
is because there's also this theory of
don't fight the trend and that doesn't
mean that you should be trendy all the
time in investing you certainly
shouldn't right you shouldn't go to a
cocktail party and just buy what the
next person says that they bought but
this is a trend now that's been around
for a few years it doesn't seem like one
that's going anywhere and i wouldn't
want to be one of those investors that
ignores it and says this isn't going to
stick around and then i miss out or i'm
not learning about it in the moment
because i've just decided that
traditional investing doesn't allow for
this type of concept yeah it makes a ton
of sense and i think that a lot of
people are kind of coming to this
conclusion as well so it's cool to see
you uh you kind of sharing that um when
you talk to somebody who is either a
young person or somebody who's just
getting started what can they do on the
sofi platform like what is that kind of
entry point uh from the invest features
it feels like there's a couple of
different things that they can do is
there one thing really hey get the
account go ahead start here and that's
what's going to get you started on this
kind of investing journey
yeah look if you're a younger investor
i'm going to paint with a broad brush
here i'm going to assume that you don't
have millions of dollars in assets right
it's probably a smaller account you just
want to get started you're a little
nervous about it you don't know a lot
about it so what you can do on our
platform is invest in little pieces so
let's take a share of stock for example
there are some shares of stock out there
that trade for over two thousand dollars
a share if you don't have a lot of money
to invest you can't buy a whole share so
we offer you the opportunity to invest
in fractional shares you also obviously
have the opportunity to invest in things
like etfs where you can buy
etfs that are diversified with smaller
amounts of money you can buy little bits
of crypto at a time and as a newer
investor that's a really important
option to have it's also an option when
you have our platform and you're in the
invest platform
or you have something in the sofi money
platform you have access to financial
planners for free so if you're starting
out in your financial journey and you
want to talk to somebody about how
you're budgeting how you're spending how
you should be investing how to pay down
your debt what are the different ways to
prioritize that we offer you those
resources as a sofa member there are so
many things that you can do on the
platform you can literally have your
entire financial life on the platform
and that's i think the biggest value
prop we have
so i've been dropping in the chat the
entire time your uh twitter account uh
people keep asking where they can follow
you just give everyone kind of the pitch
on if they follow you on twitter what uh
what's the type of content that you're
normally sharing there
sure so my twitter handle is liz young
strat
i tweet every day multiple times a day
on the markets i try to keep it some
market content some economic content and
not only will i give you some of the big
data that gets released because
obviously not everybody is sitting in
front of a bloomberg terminal all day
long like i am so give you some of the
data that's released because you're
going to hear about it in the headlines
things like inflation data things like
housing data gdp
labor market data and then also try to
explain why do we care what does that
mean right so show it here's the data
here's how it looks in comparison to
history here's what i think about it and
then market data what's the market doing
today if there's big moves in the market
today if there are certain sectors that
started to outperform other sectors if
there's a trend that we're starting to
see maybe the market has either
surpassed a recent high or fallen
through a recent low things like that
what do i think about it what do i think
is causing it so it's an easy way to
kind of keep a pulse i also share on the
twitter feed articles that i write they
come out every thursday morning
sometimes those are on thematic topics
this week's is going to be on inflation
and how to invest in an inflationary
environment sometimes they're market
calls so what i think is going to happen
for the next couple months or the next
quarter or the even the next half of the
year so you can get a lot of different
content on twitter occasionally i'll
tweet about the green bay packers i'm
from wisconsin i'm a huge wisconsin
sports fan so you're gonna have to put
up with some of that too aaron rodgers
said that he owns the bears
last week it's true yeah
sure he said i own you i've always owned
you
pretty cool all right liz listen thank
you so much for doing this uh highly
suggest again everyone please go follow
her on twitter i just dropped her
twitter account and then one more time
uh we appreciate you coming on uh my
favorite part of your twitter bios if
you want something new you have to stop
doing something old don't be old that's
how you become new so we appreciate uh
we appreciate your time today i hope
everyone learned something and we'll
definitely have to do it again in the
future
thank you all right see you later
if you want something new you got to
stop doing something old pretty damn
good right growth
but before we do that i want you guys to
do two things if you want thousand
dollars worth of bitcoin you're gonna
have to do two things the first thing is
i want you to get on your group chat i
want you to go on facebook for all of
the older people i want you to get on
telegram i want you to go dm someone on
instagram or twitter do whatever you
want like you can go paint a mural on
the side of your house go tell someone
right now come watch the show i want to
get to 10 000 people every day watching
this show go tell someone right now to
come and watch the show every day from
11 to 1. uh after you do that make sure
you're smashing the like button drop in
the chat just either your twitter handle
or your instagram handle that's it you
don't have to do anything else drop your
twitter handle or your instagram handle
and we're gonna give a thousand dollars
of bitcoin to one person
one person right now live gets a
thousand bucks content's free that means
that all you have to do is press like
button john you're picking if everyone
told one person we'd be at your goal
that's a fact five thousand by the way
before you pick real quick i want to
pull up i want to pull up two tweets
this is why i get my ass out of bed
every single day i don't need to do this
stuff anymore right but i do this every
single day because of these types of uh
of dms ready first one hi anthony and
john john wasn't in the dm but hi
anthony and john thanks for the bitcoin
love uh love the show i'll find your
brother and d him hands are shaking
thank you that's paris who won a
thousand dollars earlier already
right
already thousand bucks hands are shaking
if you come and watch this show i
promise you we will give you knowledge
and we will also give you things and you
get to laugh yeah you would definitely
of course just laugh at you easy second
one hold on second tweet second tweet
i'm 22 years old watching your show
thank you so much for your knowledge it
helps so much people that don't have
this much education exactly why we do
this every single day keep smashing the
like button all right john who's the
winner ben roberts
benny roberts 21. ben roberts yeah ben
roberts you win a thousand dollars in
bitcoin congrats everyone congratulate
ben in the co in the chat and i'm
generally happy for you congratulations
anthony scaramucci's coming on in about
eight minutes we're gonna have him come
on here one more thing that i want to
talk about before we get into uh the
interview with anthony scaramucci
there's a new report out the wealthiest
10
of american households now own 89
of all u.s stocks and mutual funds the
top 10 percent own 89
of all stocks and mutual funds when you
think about that i think it's a cnbc
article that says the top one percent
has gained over 6.5
trillion dollars in corporate equities
and mutual fund wealth during the
pandemic the bottom 90
added 1.2 trillion in wealth during the
pandemic so again this is the
bifurcation this is where we get wealth
inequality it has nothing to do with all
the nonsense that the politicians
continue to yell and scream about and
try to rip our society apart instead
this is a bipartisan issue
if you own assets you got rich as hell
over the last 18 months if you did not
own assets you didn't that's it that was
the game it's like when you get done
with the baseball game and they say well
what was the difference in the game
literally if you own assets you win if
you don't own assets you lose
6.5 trillion dollars about 6x the top 1
percent made compared to the bottom 90
of everyone during the pandemic the
total wealth of the top 1 percent
is 32
of all wealth in the world the top one
percent owns 32 percent but it's not
because they're evil people or they're
bad people they simply know one secret
in this world own assets don't hold cash
that's it if you own assets and they
continue to devalue the currency the
asset prices go up whether it's real
estate commodities equities bitcoin
whatever if you own assets it continues
to go up that is why it is so damn crazy
we've got two quotes here one from
stephen
rosenthal excuse me senior fellow urban
brookings tax policy center said quote
many of the younger investors also
bought in at higher prices compared to
bigger investors who have been in the
market for years and see larger gains
again time in the market is better than
timing the market get into the market do
your research make sure you know what
you're doing but you cannot hold cash in
this environment the second quote we
have again from stephen says they might
account for a larger share of trading
activity but that's different from
ownership and wealth many of the best
investors in the world we had uh william
green come on right he wrote richer
wiser happier one of the best books that
i've read in a long time and what he
specifically talked about is many of the
best investors in the world they own a
small number of stocks three four five
stocks they've got very heavy
concentrated positions they've done the
work they've got high conviction and
they never sell them they just bought
them and they held them for decades and
if you start to think about the
investments you make i am buying this
for my grandchildren when you get that
psychological thought process you don't
worry about did you buy it at 55 or 56
for a stock you don't worry did you buy
oil at a dollar or two dollars right it
doesn't matter if you're gonna hold it
for decades the point is to get into the
market it's more about the time in the
market than it is about trying to time
the market and so when you start to look
at some of these charts here we have the
net worth share of wealth held by u.s
households we've got the top 10 percent
in blue the bottom 90 in red why is it
that all of a sudden there's that huge
bifurcation well if you go back to 2001
what started to happen bad times started
to lead to the bifurcation it was then
accelerated in the 2008 global financial
crisis we get the rich the top 10
getting more wealthy and the bottom 90
getting less wealthy it is because we
are living in a time where any time that
there seems to be a market correction or
some sort of bear market coming the
government shows up they have a monetary
policy bazooka the politicians run to
the front lines as well and they start
dropping fiscal policy bombs on the
market and all they do is they inflate
asset prices they just manipulate the
interest rates down and they start
pumping cash into the market in every
single possible way that they can and so
people who hold the assets get wealthier
and the people who don't get absolutely
punished that's the problem now if we go
and we look at the income growth from
1917 to 2012 again we can see very
clearly when we came off the gold
standard obviously there was a massive
disparity if you look at this chart this
chart is so important the bottom 90 of
earners they were growing at a faster
rate than the top 10 percent of earners
or i'm sorry the top yeah top 1 percent
of earners the bottom 90
they were taking off when we went off
the gold standard the bottom 90 they
just went uh flat and now they're down
the bottom 90 are in a worse position
today from an income growth standpoint
than they were in 1971 but look at the
top one percent the top one percent they
chill in they can't go higher they
literally are popping why they own
assets the bottom 90
a lot of them do not own assets that is
the key to this whole game and then when
we go ahead and we look at wealth by
wealth percentile growth uh groups you
can see again that there are certain
groups that are absolutely pulling away
the top one percent continuing to gain
market share there then if we go to uh
the last chart that we have here the
rich countries tend to have a bigger
middle class except the united states
this is really important
rich countries usually have a really big
middle class except for the united
states the united states does not have a
big middle class why because we continue
to devalue the currency and our middle
class doesn't have investable assets
they're holding cash if they're holding
cash what happens they get punished
that's the problem joe and john what do
you think i mean i agree right this is
the stuff that we know though right it's
all about education is getting people to
understand they need to be that they
need to own investable assets and just
get in the market so i think there was
some uh wild sat that last year the most
brokerage accounts were created of all
time right and robin hood and all these
other brokerages were the top apps
actually in the app store for a period
of time during uh the pandemic so
hopefully a lot of people got invested
right and then we see that play out over
a period of years whether you're
investing five dollars or five million
dollars the key is just getting in and i
think what we saw during the pandemic
was more people were interested in right
you're at home you're seeing a lot of
news going on uh i tweeted something out
earlier today that
the bottom 50 percent of earners in in
the united states last year now have
checking account balances that are 50 to
70 higher on a median basis right so
people whether it was uh stimulus checks
whether it was unemployment benefits
whatever it was they were investing some
of that money right stocks went up and
their wealth went up over time so i
think the key to that is see people
finding out that that's that's the plan
right and just understanding hey look if
i put x amount of dollars in here the
stock market goes up here whatever stock
i own now i have x amount and it comes a
game right and you start to learn and
you start to uh want to do it more so i
think that over time we'll see more
people start to realize this but the key
is just getting in the market true john
get invested i mean it's it's a
no-brainer at this one right you're not
going to save yourself to be a
billionaire or a millionaire right
everyone can optimize whatever they want
um and that's doesn't just only include
stocks and cryptocurrencies right it's
real estate what is it the top 10
percent
the wealthiest top 10 percent in the u.s
holds 45 of the real estate that's crazy
there's tons of different assets that
you can get invested in just figure it
out and also make those concentrated
bets right we were talking to liz about
how
these these high-volume traders they're
not going after a hundred different
stocks they're picking their winners and
they're doing it in a concentrated
manner there's no better way of doing it
i'm taking my bet on bitcoin though and
we will uh we will see
uh you want to hear a wild stat if you
bought bitcoin on this day in 2017's
bull market four years ago if you held
till today you're up 10x
if you bought bitcoin on this day in the
2017 bull market exactly four years ago
you're up 10x and so again history does
not suggest anything about the future
but it is important to understand and
when you have a finite asset and supply
increase or i'm sorry and demand
increases then of course there's going
to be price appreciation supply-demand
economics what everyone is arguing about
is not the supply side of the equation
the supply side of the equation ends up
being known we know 21 million total
bitcoin right now there's 900 bitcoin
that are coming into the market every
single day the question is is there
going to be future demand and if you
look at it from a macro structure
standpoint it is likely to continue to
increase and therefore if you have a
finite supply asset demand increases you
do the math you ain't got to be einstein
right yeah i mean
it's true that uh you know what is the
same past performance doesn't indicate
future results but they say that in 2010
when it was at six cents they said at
2011 when it was at five dollars they
set it at 2012 when it was 12 and so
forth right last year we were at in
october 12 600 right so when everyone
was screaming and crying and saying that
it's overvalued and all these things it
consistently shows if you find a good
asset that you believe in that's going
to be here in the future and will
appreciate in value as demand continues
to rise continue to buy it and just do
it every single day every week every
month whatever it ends up being but just
get in the market and continue to invest
in it over time and with bitcoin
specifically and other assets that have
gone up in value it chose to be a
winning strategy compounding interest is
your best friend i was looking at the
chart of warren buffett the other day
and just seeing how how much it's grown
recently because of how much the
compound interest has helped him it is
ridiculous and it's good for him right
he's he's been doing it for such a long
time and he took those bets early on and
kind of let them ride compound interest
is your best friend go get invested
sofi.com anthony scaramucci is late
we're go hey you guys want to screw with
somebody today we're going to get
anthony ready anthony's late so guess
what we're going to do i just dropped
this twitter account i want everyone to
go tweet at scaramucci right now and be
like you're late just be like at
scaramucci you're late if he's going to
be late then you're going to get shark
attack that's how this show works we we
might not necessarily
be the most professional people in the
world but we have fun that's all that
matters so right now go and tweeted
anthony scaramucci telling me he's late
i don't know where he is what he's doing
but we got to get him in here he's
coming on the show we're going to talk
all about bitcoin we're going to talk
about uh institutional adoption how he's
thinking about it why he bought i think
it was like 400 million dollars worth of
bitcoin all kinds of different things
that we're going to be talking about
we're very close also by the way to 5
000 likes i don't want to go ahead and
uh encourage you all to hit the like
button because if we cross over five
thousand because i'm gonna give you
another thousand dollars hit the like
button hit the like button let's go you
two just like saying it because you're
not the one
this time all right so we're at 4.88
likes hopefully we can get uh mooch in
here in a second uh maybe he's sleeping
maybe he's taking a nap maybe he's
eating uh breakfast somewhere i don't
know what he's doing like let's see
what's happening we're seeing new york
nowadays yeah he's in new york all right
you want to fly up there real quick and
go grab some guys or we'll fly him down
here yeah or we can fly him down here
that's true too uh maybe he's late so
maybe that's what he's doing
should i text him right now something
crazy
you still coming on the greatest show on
turf drop your questions for anthony in
the chat and we will uh we will try to
ask them as well
he's probably going to get that and be
like what is going on right now um all
right so the second question that i have
uh for you two is when you think of the
bitcoin all-time high is this something
where uh you think people are going to
take profits or do we think that people
are going to hold uh through the
all-time high i i think there's
right like the easiest way to do this is
just watch the on-chain metrics right
like it's it's a beautiful thing that
bitcoin operates in the network uh
that has the ability to show you what's
happening in real time right so the
on-chain metrics tell you everything and
we bring will on here every week to go
through them and tell us kind of what's
going on but when you look at it no i
don't think so right there's there's
obviously a percentage of people so
there's a for those that aren't familiar
there's a large percentage of bitcoin uh
that could be lost forever or just from
people that are just never going to move
it right and then we have 85 up to 85
percent hasn't moved in 90 days and
there's kind of a portion as you look
out the time preference so there are
clearly believers and people that are
just never going to sell bitcoin it
could literally go down to one dollar
and they would not sell it like it's
just something that they believe in so
strongly that they will not sell so i
think you have to watch the metrics and
just make sure that kind of the bigger
people aren't offloading some of their
stuff but we've seen before people
offload things into the signs of a
strengthening market in a bull run so i
don't necessarily know if it's something
to be scared of uh but i think we're
also just beginning this this kind of
journey upward right i think uh we're at
66 67 000 now uh and i think the core
believers within bitcoin believe that we
have much higher to go
one thing i want to talk about real
quick is we turned on super chat i got
no clue how this works somebody told me
they messaged me they said hey turn on
super chat i want to use super chat
whatever the way that the super chats
are supposed to work is if you use the
super chat and you ask a question we're
going to answer questions uh
i messed up by the way uh i told him the
wrong time
he's like what's your problem yeah so i
just texted him he's like i got all
these people tweeting at me
i'm coming i'm coming i'm coming i'm
good i messed up i messed up so if you
use the super chat we will go ahead and
we will answer questions uh live on the
show we'll do our best to get to
everybody uh we'll see how it goes maybe
i'll turn it off in the future if it
gets crazy but we'll kind of see how
that goes the first person we have is
shirtless movers said bitcoin for us
president mobilemechanic.com okay that's
a free ad uh why i guess not because you
paid five dollars
bitcoin going to 150k next three months
this comes from tiger king coin uh okay
uh
nope don't
don't spam us don't spam hey guys thanks
for all you do for our community i'm
giving back to you pumpy pump jesus
christ all right super chat may last one
day that may be the the entire super
chat all right so anthony scaramucci is
coming on uh the big question around are
people gonna hold or not is i actually
think that we're gonna see some people
sell into the strength of the all-time
high and uh those are gonna be more
professional investors but all of the
retail individuals we're gonna see
almost no liquidity to the market
whatsoever like everyone's just going to
connect well at some point in time do
institutions do they have to basically
take some money off the table and return
some to clients
what do you mean like at some point in
time the client's like okay yeah i'm up
i don't know 10x 100x on paper but where
where are my returns like i want to
basically i want to reallocate to
different assets and i want to uh get
back to those certain percentages
we have
anthony scaramucci with us right now the
greatest show on turf anthony are you
there
i am i appreciate you including me guys
i'm sorry i'm a couple minutes late
you're not late i already told him i
screwed up i screwed up it's big to be
on with you as you know and uh
i'm listening carefully to the
conversation and i can just give my two
cents the people that don't understand
it they will trade it and the people
that understand it
are going to hold on for dear life
because they recognize that they've got
waterfront property they've got
waterfront irreplaceable digital
property uh that's going to appreciate
for generations and so they're not going
to trade it but i think
your point is well taken that there will
be professional traders that that trade
this thing
um and they'll take their profits you
know and even you know my close friend
uh jim cramer
several months ago you may have
remembered this pomp you got him into
bitcoin you helped me get into bitcoin
which i want to thank you for
uh but you know jim said he sold it to
pay down his mortgage that's what old
fogies like me and jim cramer do with
money you know
the the mortgage is at one point eight
one point nine percent and the inflation
rate is at eight percent but we're
selling we're buying down our mortgages
because that's what our parents told us
to do because they lived through the
depression you know of course it's a new
world now we're going to talk about
bitcoin actually i'm glad that you're
doing this from your office because the
table right behind you is where you and
i first talked about bitcoin so we'll
get to that in a second i'm going to
grab that coffee now that i see them all
right
and it looks like i got little pumps
i'm the only baby boomer here you guys i
got to get ready
starbucks the first question i see in
the chat is do you have pants on i do i
swear to god
i got a big meeting this afternoon with
one of my clients and i'm in the office
amazing if this was my home office i'd
be wearing my 1981
phys ed champions
phys ed shorts
i'm actually i'm actually in briony
which is a sign of how poor i am
it's only billionaires like you guys
that dress like
are you allowed to curse on this bomb
yeah you can say whatever you want yeah
i mean i mean look at the way you guys
dress
i mean you know this is a sign that you
guys are billionaires and i'm out here
uh you know schlepping for a living
yeah my brother does have sandals on
uh all right let's talk just kind of
macro environment and kind of monetary
policy uh you said that the inflation
rate is eight percent the fed says that
it's five point four percent i tend to
think you're closer explain why you
think it's eight and they think it's
five
well i mean the transitory number was
eight you know let's give them whatever
they want you want to say it's five
that's a ridiculous number that means
you're in negative rate territory in the
united states that means you're in my uh
intellectual mentor paul tudor jones is
reporting this morning what you and i
both know the obituary for the 60 40
portfolio has already been written and
now the question is what are we going to
do where are we going to go
and you discovered before i did that
there are digital hard assets
that are going to replace fiat assets
because unfortunately like nakamoto said
11 or 12 years ago
we corrupt those assets and so
you caught me in this room on your
earlier versions of your podcast where
we were talking about the history of
money i wasn't yet in bitcoin but i was
indicating to you why i was moving that
way
because we've now jumped the shark to
use a happy days expression on money if
you've made
and you know these numbers pom because i
follow you on twitter you know you tell
me what's the m2 up 40 40 40 percent
yeah 40
yeah let's just call it 40 for the sake
of this argument okay uh what what what
amount of money has been printed well if
you look through the beige book
uh it was 592 billion dollars at the end
of may
i can only guess because i haven't seen
the recent number but i'm going to say
it's close to
i don't know 650 billion dollars has
been printed by the federal reserve this
year
uh so that's going to show up in the
inflation data that
that's killing the people
in our family
that didn't get educated or don't own
bitcoin you know i'm from a family of
immigrants as you know italian
immigrants my dad was a crane operator
a lot of my
contemporaries my cousins are
clamming in oyster bay they're cutting
deli meat they're installing auto glass
they can't catch up with this nonsense
you and i can own assets our assets are
going to appreciate and our standard of
living will be just fine but if you're a
wage holder and the federal reserve is
printing 700 billion dollars of money
you're screwed pom and i and i told you
that when we first met when they broke
the contract with gold in 1971
they slowly eroded middle and lower
middle class living standards and now
we're living in an age of populism
economic desperation for a large group
of people which used to be economic
aspiration
and we've weakened the society so when
you see something like bitcoin you're
like oh my god this is a technological
innovation
which can actually be a store of value
for those people
can help the underbanked
and could literally transform the world
and if we get this thing right and it
exponentially networks to the billion
plus users that you and i both think
we'll get to
well then hold on it's gonna check it's
going to hand check the bankers the
central bankers they're going to be
forced into a box
of fiscal responsibility and conformity
because if they don't do that there's
another option for human beings
aka bitcoin or you pick one of the other
cryptocurrencies that you like but you
get you get the point that i'm making
for sure and one of the things i don't
think people really appreciate well
there's two points with you right so one
is you're a student of history i
remember when we did the podcast you
laid out the history of money better
than uh anyone i walked out of there and
i said i don't know how that guy
remembers all that information but he's
like an encyclopedia the second thing is
that when you decided to actually enter
the market i believe you guys bought 400
million dollars of bitcoin was kind of
the first foray
you have a very very good memory yeah is
that correct
yes that is correct and so uh we are
sitting on a little over a billion
dollars of bitcoin
um to your brother's comment uh we've
had to sell some
because
in our fund now i have a core bitcoin
fund the first trust skybridge bitcoin
fund that's a total huddling situation
i've got a lot of money in that
personally but in our flagship fund sort
of the nine billion dollars that we're
running um we started with 400
uh would have loved to have left it but
i can't be in a situation in the
flagship fund where bitcoin is eating up
the whole fund so
i i i took some out of there we sold
some uh uh but we're going to leave it
for right now it may trade back to 50
000. i don't know
what i do know though
is it's likely to get to 150 000 over
the next 12 months i'm going to stick
with my earlier price target that i
shared with you on our salt talk when
you did my podcast i think it's a
hundred thousand by year end
um and i just think it's that because
there's now
a gateway opened guys you know this
anthony a gateway opened yesterday
where an institution can now say i can
buy this
um you know if you're a vaxxer or an
anti-vaxxer some of my friends said well
i'm not getting vaccinated until the fda
approves the vaccine
and so that sort of metaphorically
happened for bitcoin you got an approval
from the sec bitcoin lives
in the financial regulatory ecosystem
and it's not going anywhere and now that
portal has opened for
a sophisticated early adopting
institution to say it's okay for me to
step in the water here i'm not going to
get fired if i own this thing so one of
the things that's really interesting is
that you manage billions of dollars
you've been doing this for quite a long
time very successful at doing so
you
don't normally strike people from the
crypto community as why would anthony
scaramucci and sky bridge be
participating here and when i talk to
you i think that you see kind of the
writing on the wall right the world is
shifting to this new digital economy and
it feels like uh based on what i know
that you're taking sky bridge and kind
of slowly starting to say hey look we
want to include this in kind of the
aperture of what we look at is there a
world where skybridge ever goes all in
on bitcoin cryptocurrencies or do you
think that having a parallel strategy is
kind of the winning strategy and i'm as
in as you can be yeah you know i'm going
to be 58 years old in january i'm pretty
in right i mean i got a billion dollars
of this stuff uh and i've laid in i've
got a a uh etf those are for my
fuddy-duddy friends you remember there's
fud which is fear uncertainty and doubt
and then you've got duddies which are
these old people that won't own bitcoin
i created crypt for them crpt
trades on the new york stock exchange
it's a crypto proxy effectively it's you
know microstrategy and coinbase and
marathon and so it has unbelievable
correlation to bitcoin
um i've raised an ethereum fund i think
you know i have an investment in
algorand which i think is a fascinating
technical property uh but i'm all in
we've got almost a billion dollars in
bitcoin
i wrote a book
and again anthony this is an
international best seller
and if you don't believe me you can come
into my warehouse back here at sky
bridge where i've bought every share or
every book to make sure it was
[Laughter]
i mean come on no one's ever bought one
of my books so i'll tell your listeners
uh my email okay okay it's acaramucci at
skybridge.com if you want a copy of the
book you're listening to the pops
podcast i'll mail you one a scaramucci
skybridge.com
it's a short little pamphlet but it'll
explain it to your parents
okay it'll explain to your parents what
it is
and the subtitle is how i stop worrying
about cryptocurrency
and you should too so i'm all in it
it took me longer than you because i'm
an institutionalist i said to you
in our first podcast 100 million wallets
a place where i can store it and not
worry about it because i'm going to be
in deep you know with nine figures if
not 10 figures
and then the third thing is what's the
regulatory landscape
is the united states going to accept
this and so last year
right around this time all three of
those things seemed like they were going
to happen
uh and so then we started buying those
coins
and we're in and i expect our business
to continue to morph into more digital
assets but you asked me a really
good question that i want to answer
how does an old fart like me
see it
and the answer to that is i have to
listen to young farts like the three of
you
and and i think we make a very big
mistake generationally
if we're not listening to each other
like you guys could avail yourself to my
experience dealing with volatile markets
dealing with the ups and downs of
entrepreneurship
the humbling nature of life
like if you're having a bad day think of
my ass getting fired from the white
house in july of 19
you know july of 2017 july 31st as an
example right and so you can learn from
me in terms of how to roll with the
punches and bounce when you need to but
i can learn from you where the future is
going
because you and your team the best
business show anthony pompliano you guys
are creating the future
that my children and grandchildren are
going to live in and if i close my mind
to that if i act like the 97 year old
charlie munger and i say oh it's the
worst thing that's ever happened in
civilization
that means i've lost my neuroplasticity
that i've lost my ability to adapt and
learn
so my
message to everybody listening everybody
watching you
we can learn from each other let's not
close our minds and reconfirm our biases
let's open our minds
and let's
test our theories on each other and you
know i i want to say thank you to i was
with michael saylor yesterday i thanked
him i want to say thank you to you
um you were very influential in helping
me see
what was going on in the blockchain and
and in bitcoin i i appreciate it you you
taught me plenty don't you worry i i
should be thanking you not me uh not you
taking me talk to me about institutional
interest and what you're seeing in terms
of kind of your peers or colleagues and
what they're thinking about uh the asset
class
so people get mad at me pomp because
they asked me honestly and i said i
don't see it i've got my my guys out
here said yeah what are you doing why
are you telling people that there's no
interest in the institutional community
and i'm like because i don't see it if i
saw it i would say it i want to be
straight up with people you know and and
i thought there was going to be way more
institutional interest at the beginning
of the year january 2021
then manifest but now i'll make a bold
prediction anthony
i think there's going to be
institutional interests over the next 12
to 18 months because you now have gotten
the regulatory box checked and that
checking of that box is going to lead to
institutions saying hey i got to get in
this thing i've got to own a piece of
this i've got to understand it and what
would george soros say
he would say invest and investigate
later you've heard that aphorism and i
think you're now going to start to see
it but i didn't see it over the last
eight or nine months
and that's just me being straight up
with you
how do you think about the etf launch
yesterday it's got 570
million dollars of assets uh at the end
of the day yesterday did about a billion
dollars in uh you know kind of uh on
market and after hour trading does that
start to signal that there's more
institutional interest or would you be
surprised if there wasn't more than that
so i think two things are happening okay
number one people are wading into the
etf you know it's a futures etf so
there's some issues there i don't want
to bore everybody with the specifics
there but i would prefer a cash spot etf
over futures i understand why gary
gensler when commissioner gensler went
in that direction but there's two things
going on people are buying the etf
but you've got institutions now calling
knighted calling galaxy calling gemini
and and fidelity and saying okay i want
a wallet i want to store some bitcoin on
your premises or coinbase institutional
you know and that's happening my friends
have said to me where are your coins
stored can you refer me to somebody
where they want to buy the direct coin
now
so you've got two things happening
money's flowing into the etf that's
fantastic
but money's also flowing into the asset
directly in the cash market
uh from these institutions
joe john what questions you guys got hey
anthony thanks for doing this and nice
to meet you
uh
was that a pause where you wanted him to
say something no
i thought he was the younger pup or the
older pump or the medium pop i'm in the
middle out of us three all right so
you're the you're the mama bear pomp
i don't know if i like that but all
right all right we'll let it slide uh
all right as someone who uh so bitcoin
historically has been a pretty volatile
asset obviously right as someone who has
dealt more with uh maybe traditional
equity markets or things like that and
manages billions of dollars for clients
how do you get individual clients
comfortable with that volatility
um
well you have to size it appropriately
so that's one of my issues in my core
fund if i put a four percent position
and the and it grows to 20 percent
i have to probably scale it back so that
i can calm down my investors uh so what
i tell people if you're a bitcoin
maximus come into my bitcoin fund if
you're in my other fund let me size it
appropriately because it will be
volatile
but you guys know this and but i think
there's some historical perspective
necessary to share here
all these
medcap law
network effect
investments they start out in the early
adoption phase with mega volatility why
you've got all the fuddy-duddies and the
ancients shorting it disbelieving it
shorting tesla
shorting amazon amazon is going to miss
its number it's 19.99 let me short the
goddamn thing
and
they
create the volatility same thing happens
in bitcoin you know we hit an air pocket
uh with elon musk and china bitcoins at
65 000. it's at 29 000. i've got clients
lighting me up
and you guys know this everybody's a
long-term investor until they have
short-term losses when they have
short-term losses they set their hair on
fire they run around in a circle and so
i m one of my jobs is to be the
financial
and psychological coach i've got to tell
people calm down
uh stay the course we have a five-year
plan or a three-year plan and i'll just
point out because i think it's worth
mentioning if you were an early investor
in amazon
you know just think about this for a
second the ipo of amazon may 15 1997
a ten thousand dollar investment is now
worth 21 million dollars 21 million 140
000
however you would have had to subject
yourself to eight periods of time where
it dropped at least 50 percent
one period of time where it went down 85
and the barons newspaper had a front
page article amazon.bomb
the age of this internet retailer is
over
but the cat that made amazon jeff bezos
he shot himself into space in his own
rocket
okay so what do you guys want to do do
you want to be patient
and look at something like bitcoin and
see the exponential growth of wallets
and the scale and understand the value
of the network effect of those
properties associated there with
and stay patient
and watch bitcoin
eclipse gold in terms of its market
capitalization
or do you want to trade it and get juked
out of it at the wrong moment and do
what
non-psychologically minded investors do
is they sell lows and they buy highs
and so to me i got to get in the face i
got to get in i have to grab the face
mask of my clients and pull them close
to me like a good coach and say stop it
get your emotions out of this thing
this is a revolutionary asset this is
digital
waterfront property this is digital
energy
that is going to transform the world and
over the blockchain we are going to
de-layer
our society we're going to take
third-party
intermediaries out of the society
there'll be a cost savings it'll be
ecologically friendly
there will be quantum benefits
associated with this and you can own a
piece of this property today
at a very attractive price this is you
and me pomp going to miami beach in 1921
and buying oceanfront property facts so
i have one more question it sounds you
mentioned that you think uh bitcoin is
going to overtake gold right so
bitcoin's market cap i believe today is
like 1.1 one and a quarter trillion 1.25
trillion uh and gold is around 11
trillion so do you have any estimates or
kind of uh you know how long you think
that might take to happen
you know it's a very good question i'm
just checking markets right now yep and
you know you know i i would say
realistically
um if you've got a in my opinion you've
got to get to a billion wallets
and so
you know
i'll go with kathy ward's estimate kathy
is saying to people end of 2024
mid 2025 you'll be at a billion wallets
and so if you think of the scarcity of
bitcoin
i think it would be worth probably five
or six hundred thousand dollars a coin
by then
and uh
you know
there you go that's where it is by the
way i'm sure you've had sailor on if you
haven't had them on you can get them on
yesterday when i spoke to michael you
know he doesn't think this is a 10
trillion dollar asset he thinks it's a
hundred trillion dollar asset he thinks
he thinks this is at least 10 times
more valuable than gold and you know
anthony's heard me say this one of my
saudi friends said to me
anthony when people ask you is this more
valuable than gold or not tell them this
story i said what is that shake he said
well right now mbs loves me
but there may come a day where mbs
doesn't love me i have a usb with 200
million dollars of bitcoin and since
this is a family show i won't tell you
where the shakes suggested he was going
to put the bitcoin as he headed for the
yemeni border okay but he can't put 200
million dollars of gold
in the place that he was describing to
me
but he came with bitcoin yeah exactly so
you get you get the point i'm making and
so therefore the technical properties of
bitcoin the network effect is actually
way more valuable than gold
so i'm i'm an institutionalist guys you
guys are younger than me and smarter
than me
i've got to get my clients
over the hump
of owning digital property okay you guys
are already living in that world i've
got to get the 60 year old to say whoa
whoa i've got guys like jamie dimon
telling these people it's worthless you
know and that that's not helping me in
my you know larry think well i'm sort of
siding with jamie dimon
okay but then my attitude is well these
guys obviously haven't done enough
homework because somebody like ray dalio
was a bitcoin skeptic he did the
homework
he's bought bitcoin uh paul tudor jones
a skeptic
bought bitcoin after doing the homework
so i'm just telling people do the
homework you know and if you do the
homework you're going to want to get
long some of this in your portfolio john
yeah anthony thank you for doing this
nice to uh nice version meet you so i
love how you talk about the emotional
side of things when stocks and assets
are going
i need one of those hats though but i'm
hoping well you know me that had it it
says bitcoin 150 000.
but anyway i'm sorry go ahead yeah no
you're good uh yeah when assets are
going up people don't think it's going
to stop and when they're going down they
say they're never going to go back up
again so you got to take the emotional
thing that's why people hire you
um so can you talk about the etf stuff
going on when do you think a spot etf
will be approved do you think only one
will be approved like can you just talk
about the regulations behind all that
and what gary you think is thinking
so i'm sort of not allowed to talk about
it because i'm in the quiet period
because i have filed okay so what i can
say
is uh something i think gary gensler
would appreciate
is
regulatory oversight on
pricing
and the surety and accuracy of pricing
and so
as you guys know uh one of the criteria
for etfs is that there really can't be
any pricing manipulation
or any securities in there that a whale
can come in and
you know force the thing down or force
it up by reducing supply
and why gary likes the futures market he
was the former chairman of the cftc
bitcoin futures have been around and
regulated by the cftc for many years and
he's confident that you don't have any
of that going on
in the futures markets so it's not to
say that
he's not confident about it in the cash
markets but i think he needs to figure
out a way
to have more regulatory oversight over
the cash markets and so
when that actually happens or when that
step takes place
in his mind in the commission's mind
i'm not sure
but if you're asking me do i think it
will happen i do think it will happen
i think gary has signaled to people
that he does not want the united states
to lose its mantle of financial
leadership he doesn't want us
to turn off the best ideas in
fintech and d5 and just imagine the
united states
at the turn of the 20th century saying
oh
that combustion engine and that
horseless carriage we're not into that
let's let the europeans
build those and let the asians build
those we're going to stick with the
horse and carriages
okay so what i applaud gary gensler in
doing is saying
we're moving into the future we're
probably going to get dragged into the
future by a younger generation of people
and i'm okay with that i just got to
make sure that the pricing mechanisms
are fair and safe and market-based does
that make sense joe yep
mooch i got a question that uh i don't
want to ask you something that you're
not allowed to talk about but uh what's
going on with sovereign wealth funds any
insights that you can share in terms of
it feels like that's the non-regulatory
stuff i can totally so it feels like we
had individuals they ran wall street
institutions et cetera then we started
to get the institutions those
institutions were financial institutions
and uh corporations of a public
insurance insurance companies insurance
balance sheets that cohort basis is now
in and getting in uh the last two are
nation states and sovereign wealth funds
uh we know that el salvador is obviously
in there's probably some other countries
the united states doesn't like as much
that are doing things just not
announcing it
the sovereign wealth funds a lot of
people haven't been talking about it's
like what what's your thoughts there or
any insights that you can share
yeah they're coming the cyber wealth
funds are on the way uh some of them
have already established small stakes in
them
i'm making a trip uh next week to the
middle east i'll be speaking at the fii
conference in riyadh i have a whole
slate of meetings with different
sovereign wealth funds related to this
topic i think i think that they're
open-minded you know i i will share this
with you i won't i can't give you the
name of the fund but i have one middle
eastern sovereign wealth fund that's a
big investor of mine
and they really wanted to redeem
on me uh when i made the bitcoin
investment and i begged them to be
patient i begged them not to and then of
course anthony what happened was bitcoin
went from 65 000 to 29 000 and i have to
confess to you that the heat was on me
uh and i went over there to see people
and i said please you know
you know be patient here's how we're
thinking about this and yesterday i got
a call
from the head guy and he said you know i
just want to thank you
for bringing me into the future i now
see
what you saw
and you were bold enough to to to do
that for me and he said something
interesting i'll share with you says you
know you've got these art consultants
uh and joan whitney payson who owned the
mets
uh her daughter once said well god bless
our art consultant because there was a
there was an artist that cut his ear off
named vincent van gogh and we bought the
art for 300 000
and in 1987 we sold it for 41 million
which was a big number back in 1987 and
she was like well thank god for that art
consultant because he saw something in
that artist
that was going to manifest itself into
the future and that's what you're doing
with the best business show and that's
what you pomplianos are doing you're
showing somebody something
that's happening
and
because it's hard to believe
and i'll say something to you that it
sounds too good to be true
so they don't want to do it and when
you're an old guy like me and somebody
says well something that's too good to
be true you run you don't want to do
something that's too good to be true but
let me show you something that's too
good to be true this see it
this is too good to be true
okay that eats up the world it takes all
the
books of my library all the photographs
i've got access now to all the
information let me ask you something
would you like to roam the library
congress or have my smartphone to do a
research report what would you like to
do would you like to go to the dewey
decimal system in the library of
congress or would you like my smartphone
fully charged for the day what would you
like for years i've always thought the
dewey decimal system was stupid
yeah all right but you know the point
i'm making is this phone is too good to
be true and the market capitalization of
amazon
or apple too good to be true ten
thousand dollars going to 21
million dollars in 24 years too good to
be true so this is
technical properties that are happening
before our eyes
and we either have to accept and embrace
them
and be willing to
propitiously allocate to them so let's
say you don't believe me or you don't
believe anthony pompliano
how about a half a percent of your
portfolio how about one percent of your
portfolio you know plan b i think you've
interviewed him pomp plan b said to me
on my podcast
if you took one cent
and you put it in bitcoin 10 years ago
and you had 99 cents in cash and that
was your asset allocation that was your
tactical asset allocation model it
outperformed everything
everything
okay so guys put a half a percent in put
put a percent in this is the early
innings of a technological revolution
where the blockchain and things like
bitcoin are going to delay the society
you know if i if i were american express
or visa i'd be worried because the
transaction speeds permitted over the
blockchain are way faster it's way
cheaper
why do i have to as a merchant accept a
three percent charge
ten years from now why will i have to do
that
if everyone's got a smart wallet and a
smartphone
and uh some interac interoperability
on the internet
over the blockchain why would i have to
do that guys you're not gonna have to
obviously
right well no no more you see aunt you
don't remember this you you kids are
italian kids but i'm gonna set you in
1985 probably before the three of you
were born i'm waiting in rome at the
post office
to get to a phone booth
to connect to an att operator to call my
mother okay to let her know because i
could call her once a week it was three
dollars a minute i could get her on the
phone and let her know i'm okay so i
waited online i got into the phone booth
att operator here's my credit card hi
ten dollar phone call for three minutes
fast forward we're doing this costless
over the internet
right i can i can log onto a wi-fi in an
italian cafe make a internet phone call
to my mother for no charge
that's what's going to happen to
financial services it's happening right
now
okay you just happen to
be at the forefront of it i'm a little
bit farther behind from you but trust me
i'm catching up
and i'm just trying to educate my
clients that that's what's happening
okay yes i made that phone call because
that's all we could do back in 1985 but
today i can i can talk to her over zoom
costlessly
she loves you i already know i don't
even have to talk to her she's an
italian mom she loves you
hope to god man i renovated the house
a good italian son's supposed to do you
know what i mean i pay for the gucci you
know shoes
i hope she loves me all right uh last
group i want to talk to you about and
then i'll let you go is uh rias we saw
interactive brokers just announced that
they're gonna start letting people buy
it there's companies like on-ramp and a
bunch of other options the etf now is
available are rias can we put them all
in one big bucket they're coming they're
in they're not interested you know when
you talk to that sector what's their
status
they're scared they're scared they don't
want to miss it
um they don't understand it
um they are
in the business
of what i call it the stay wealthy
business pump you know somebody comes to
me i'm an ria
they sold their business they're wealthy
uh my job is to keep them wealthy right
i've got to figure out a asset mixture
that gets them ahead of inflation and
they can still buy art at sotheby's and
i got to put them in some private equity
and get them some growth but what i
don't want to do is make big mistakes
and embarrass myself because then
they'll fire me if i make sure that they
stay wealthy
i keep my job and i stay higher you see
what i'm saying and so they're afraid
and so
they are behind me
because
it's sort of like self-conscious
embarrassment if i put three percent of
your portfolio in bitcoin it goes from
66 000 to 10 000
and you're going to look at me and say
well why the hell did you do that
because their clients don't really
understand bitcoin
and so they're afraid so what happened
yesterday
is transformational
because now they can go to clients and
say okay listen this is a technical
asset
it is a technology that represents a
networked value and it's an evolution
on money you and i talked about that the
first time we met we had wampum we had
seashells we had cloth you know we had
uh you know this this money that we call
paper money is actually not paper money
pump this is made out of linen okay look
at this okay this is for your viewers
you know what this is
those are italian those are italian
singles pop you see that
those are italian singles see those
right and because i'm old-fashioned i
always gotta have money on you never
know when you're gonna need the money to
cut and run somewhere right so look at
this this is a piece of fabric it's 75
cotton it's 25
linen
it's worthless pomp you know that and i
know that but it's got numbers on it and
it's got a an old dead white person we
only have white males on our money by
the way and we're going to trade this
with each other
why we trust this we trust that the next
guy that takes it
is going to be able to trade it for
goods and services you see what i'm
saying so now what you created satoshi
nakamoto created
is a trusted network where we don't even
have to use this anymore we don't have
to use the bank we can use that trusted
network
that decentralized
internet highway system do you see how
brilliant that is guys i mean i know you
guys see it but i'm trying to
impress it upon the people that are
listening to you
because you got the best business show
and they want to learn from you so i'm
trying to explain to them
we're moving from this and we're moving
from a magnetic strip known as a credit
card in your wallet and we're moving
from those electronic digits
you know if i want to buy a g wagon
tonight i call chase i say wire 200
grand over to the mercedes and the g
wagon shows up but those electronic
digits are worthless other than the fact
that they're a ledger they go down in my
account up in the mercedes-benz account
i got the g wagon all right how is the
bitcoin anything different from what i
just said in fact if anything my god
it's
audited
it's audited by a decentralized nodal
system
and it's airtight and it's a fixed
supply you tell me what i'm missing bob
you tell me what i'm missing invite
somebody on like peter schiff
who's you know tutte potts
which for the non-italians that's like a
chicken running in somebody's head
doesn't even know what he's talking
about
you know and i'm trying to be polite to
the guy when i debate him but what are
you talking about peter
all right before i i was gonna let you
go but i gotta ask one question you
brought up a g right anything
you want anything you want i'm i'm i'm
finally caffeinating so i'm i know i
felt like i know you guys felt i was a
little under energized for this thing no
no no no no you're you're always
bringing the energy what's the craziest
thing you've ever bought
like what like you just you look back
and you're like man that was nuts
all right whatever the thing you just
thought of that's what i want to hear
you gotta understand this so you gotta
let me stipulate okay i'm nouveau
reached italian right my dad was a crane
operator my mother was a homemaker when
i got into harvard law school anthony my
mother thought it was hartford law
school she had no clue you know she was
like ready to take me to hartford
connecticut i'm like no ma it's in
boston well why the hell would they call
it hartford law school if it's in boston
because it's called harvard ma right i
mean that's the family i grew up in so i
had no money as a kid i started making
money
the stupidest thing i bought was the
batmobile
from the 1992
batman returns movie
starring michael keaton michelle
pfeiffer and danny devito
and i owned that for about 10 years
and i used to put the bat
outfit on and drive it around on
halloween with my kids okay and by the
way it wasn't you couldn't drive the
thing there was no license plate or
anything like that it was a it was a
prop car and i used to bottom out
everywhere in port washington when i was
driving around in it but there was a
propane tank in the back you could flip
the switch and the flames would shoot
out of the back it was it was effing
fantastic
italian
italians love cars okay
so now you know now now i have the
garden variety lamborghini because i
love cars i mean what am i gonna do of
course i'm gonna have a lamborghini when
i was when i was a kid i had a 1979
camaro
and some day i said yeah i'm gonna make
some money and i want a lamborghini so i
eventually bought one but
uh about
15 16 years ago
uh i sold that it's now in a museum in
abu dhabi at their automotive museum but
it was a lot of fun to own it for the
years that i had it that might be the
best answer i've ever got to that
question to have the batmobile that
shoots out fire is incredible it was
yeah it was hooked up to a pro you had
to make sure no one hit anybody
rear-ended you it was going to be a
really badass
just let you know it was not it was not
road appropriate but i did drive it
around in my hometown on halloween with
the batman outfit on you got to send me
a picture of you in the batman outfit
you just just i
back then we didn't have smartphones so
i don't have no idea where the hell
these pictures are i'd have to find them
awesome uh i've dropped your uh your
twitter account go follow anthony on uh
on twitter absolute great follow you got
a million followers by the way that is a
a big feat what did you start the year
at
well no look i you know i think that was
from the politics to be candid you know
um but uh
i don't even know what i started the
year at i don't look at it that
carefully
uh but listen you know i think uh
i think you're gonna be uh the 10
million follower man before long you
know you and plan b
are going to be the two uh twitter
heroes of uh of bitcoin listen
i'm a little bit too political you know
i want people to get vaccinated
i i think donald trump is completely
nuts you know so i'm gonna be a little
bit more opinionated than you you forget
all the politics for a second in terms
of the different parties you i do have
to say
you gave the greatest press conference
performance of all time when you hit
everyone with the finger gun
when you're in the white house i told
you this before
[Laughter]
the point the point is they're asking
tough questions i'm giving them tough
answers i'm not going to sit there and
get rolled by anybody
you know and you know i i know my facts
and i'm coming to play
and i could have helped trump but you
know i made a mistake i got myself fired
that's another big lesson for people i
never blame my firing on anybody but me
i got myself fired i said something
which was really effing funny but
inappropriate and i got fired let's move
on general kelly and i
are great friends today he fired me he's
been to my saw conference three times
we've done public speeches around the
country together
and life moves on when you make a
mistake
the number one lesson as an investor or
a person
is forget it what are you going to do
you're not going to walk around with the
millstone of regret on your neck every
morning i don't wake up in the morning
and say let me kick myself in the pants
i did something stupid that got my ass
fired at the white house four years ago
i said today's a brand new day
let's go what do you say is pump seize
the day let's get after whatever you say
every morning
that's what we got to do
right relentlessly get after things
and be in love with life you know and if
you're taking yourself too seriously
look in the mirror relax you know what
does mel brooks say relax none of us are
getting out of here alive okay you're
not living forever i mean you may end up
in the singularity because you're
younger than me but i doubt it you'll be
in the grave so go have a glass of
scotch and relax a little too you know
and buy some bitcoin perfect
buy some you got to you got to own
bitcoin bitcoin is going to be a big
part of the future
and i hope i hope your your people are
listening to you bob and your brothers i
uh i i appreciate it very much where can
uh if people want to learn more about
sky bridge where should we send them
well you know you can go obviously to
skybridge.com
you can email me i gave out my email
right it's a scaramucci
at skybridge.com i'll send you a packet
of information we could set up a call
whatever you guys want to do i i'm happy
to get these books my assistant's ready
to kill me i got all these books loaded
up in our our storage facility i'm happy
to send those out you just let me know
i'll mail i'll mail you one if you're
one of palms friends you're one of my
friends anthony scaramucci author of a
new york times but no i don't know if
new york times but a best-selling book
because he bought them all himself
internet
comp you got to get the verbies right
this these are international i've
written five books they're all
international bestsellers
but no one other than me has ever bought
the book so you go figure out that okay
you figure out how many books i've got
in storage
you're doing a great job all right
listen thank you for taking the time to
do this i know you're busy so i
appreciate it and real pleasure to be on
aunt thank you and and guys best of luck
to you guys and i i need a hat that says
bitcoin 150 joe
we're on it we're on it
all right thank you all right bye
thoughts
well he got our names mixed up but uh
outside of that that was wild when he
called me uh mama bear
oh yeah
everyone in the chat loved that they
come in he called you mama
he's great though i like him a lot i've
never talked to him 400 million dollars
of bitcoin they bought savage now worth
over a billion worth of billion bucks
now yeah
all right ready
cross over 5000 likes you know what that
means
giving out one more wait before we get
to that can we just talk about the fact
that he called a hundred dollar bills
italian singles
and pulled his wild and pulled out about
about ten thousand dollars yeah
you gotta keep a little bit cash get out
of here
it's in case you need to get out of here
what
when i heard him say italian singles i
immediately looked over at john and
john's like
i mean
he was in a f-14 fighter jet they're
taking off that's an all-time long
you're gonna start calling them italian
singles too no i'm gonna call 100 bills
i'm gonna call them italian singles
that's all right all right good
a thousand dollars of bitcoin going to
one person in the chat here's what i
want you to do i want you to take this
i'm gonna give you right now
this link i want you to go tweet the
link and tell people to come watch the
show make sure they're subscribing
that's the key
once you have done that come back here
and drop your twitter account
we're gonna pick one person they're
gonna get a thousand dollars right now
by the way
while we're waiting for people to go do
that
i don't want to say who it is
but somebody texted me in a group chat
joe i think you're in this group chat
and they said jack mullers is the next
bill gates
[Laughter]
hopefully without a couple of the oh i
don't know if we're supposed to i don't
want a bill we
[Applause]
but all right john are you picking yeah
i'll pick someone who's getting a
thousand
dollars or you know 10 italian singles
all right let's uh
that's why you don't do public mad
what are you talking about a hundred
dollars oh oh i thought we were giving
away uh
more than that
oh yeah you can give away money no i'm
good with that all right ten thousand
thousand dollars in bitcoin
i'm just making sure they tweet the link
oh john doing due diligence
john don't play liar they lie
they lie don't play games around here my
boy john's coming for you
he said you lied all right i'm gonna
check one more
and then
if not i'm just gonna pick someone just
out of being a good guy no we're going
check too
by the way oh we got some one
robert ellingham
robert
allingham you win
a thousand dollars in bitcoin
let's go all right i'm not gonna say the
other person's name but that's what
happens when you lie karma gets you i
picked you but you didn't do it we asked
so sorry about that try again
i don't know if you should be sorry i
mean no i look sorry you should be sorry
as well for not doing it and saying that
you did it
all right
any last words do we have all the
information we need today
make sure please hey listen you at home
right there watching listen this is
important very important
two things that i need from you one make
sure you subscribe to the channel if you
subscribe to the channel when we go live
you'll get a notification you'll come in
here to be great we're gonna be doing
this all through the end of the year and
bitcoin's gonna keep going up through
the end of the year it's gonna be
awesome we'll have a lot of fun we're
gonna give out a lot of money all this
stuff gonna be amazing you're gonna
learn a bunch you're gonna laugh you're
gonna earn a bunch
like that yup
second thing i need you to do you need
to go to sofi.com when you go to
software.com pop you can sign up for
their invest account when you go there
you can buy stocks buy commodities you
can buy all the stuff or you can buy
bitcoin if you go and you put 10 in of
bitcoin uh or you buy 10 worth of
bitcoin they'll give you ten dollars for
free if you put two thousand dollars in
then you'll join the diamond heads club
you get to join calls with us you get to
go into a slack you get to do all this
cool stuff so go to software.com make
sure you read the terms and conditions i
don't want to get any sort of problems
and we will
keep going any last words from two
geniuses it's gonna be a fun uh few
months to end out the year
john scaramucci's legend i appreciate
all of you guys watching thanks for
liking the video subscribe to the
channel if you want tweet at me i'll
respond and uh pay off your credit card
and that's it for the best business show
we'll be back tomorrow we got a big
guest big guest tomorrow
big guest tomorrow see you guys tomorrow
[Music]
you